the jurogan experience i wonder if
that's a real guy in there
like a skeleton did you know there was a
they found uh there was a buddha statue
once and they found out that it was
actually a mummified buddha that they
had covered with a statue they did an
x-ray on this thing and inside of it is
like an actual buddha guy like an actual
yogi who was in a lotus position
that they did the statue around him well
that's not that weird well it's weird
that they didn't know it people had this
statue they didn't know it was a dead
how old was the statue that's a good
question because if it was you know i
mean there's tombs and mummies and
everything all over the place but look
at the statue i think that's unreal
that's what i want that's crazy right
see like that thing he ain't clicking
that thing a little thing in the corner
he has to sign up to the history channel
right because he's like yeah right he's
not actually every time go can you pull
back up to the images again like so is a
a monk a mummified monk inside an
ancient buddhist statue which is wild
man because i don't know what the statue
is made of but it looks like is it look
very pottery what does that look like
medical examination of a
thousand-year-old buddha statue revealed
a shocking surprise hidden inside an
actual person's body
so um
meander
medical center in the dutch town of
amsterfoot
of course amsterfort has plenty of
experience treating senior citizens but
none as old as the one thousand-year-old
patient who came
researchers brought a millennium old
statue of buddha of the buddha which had
been on loan from the drence museum in
the netherlands to the state-of-the-art
hospital in the hopes that the modern
medical technology should could shed
light on an ancient mystery
for hidden inside the gold painted
figure was uh
was a secret the mummy of a buddhist
monk in the lotus position shown outside
of china for the first time last year so
how do they know though that's what's
confusing did they open it up did they
ruin the whole thing and open it up i
don't think they did man just leave it
in there they sampled the material for
dna it said uh
huggleman slid an ancient artifact
slowly into a high-tech imaging machine
for a full body ct scan and sampled bone
material for dna testing
gastroenterologist
say that word gastro gastroenterologist
and say say his name now
try that uh roy now vermin flannel
[Laughter]
the vermin she did verbiage did
used a specialty a specially designed
endoscope to extract samples from the
mummy's chest and abdominal cavities
now it's known the tests have revealed a
surprise the monk's organs had been
removed and replaced with scraps of
paper printed with ancient chinese
characters and other rotted materials
since it's not been identified how the
organs have been taken from the mummy
remains a mystery wow that's cool i
wonder why they knew there was something
in there though like it's not normal
that you threw a [ __ ] yeah you go
into a ct scan
so look scroll up there no you're right
there the body inside the statue is
thought to be that of the buddhist
master
liu kwan a member of the chinese
meditation school who died around a.d
1100 how did luqun's body end up in i
hope i'm saying that right end up inside
ancient chinese statue one possibility
explored by the drenched museum is is
the gruesome process of
self-mummification
in which monks hoped to transform
themselves into revered living buddhas
oh
whoa he put himself in there the
practice of self-mummification amongst
buddhist monks was most common in japan
but occurred elsewhere in asia including
china as described in ken jeremiah's
book living buddhas monks interested in
self-mummification spent upwards of a
decade following a special diet that
gradually starved their bodies and
enhance their chances of preservation
holy [ __ ]
they eschewed any food i never know how
to say that word because i only read it
how do you say that word a shoot
issued that's a word that i've never
said issued i'm 54. i've never seen that
word i've seen that word but i've only
read it i've never actually said it out
loud
any food made from rice wheat and
soybeans and instead ate nuts berries
tree bark and pine needles
and slowly diminishing quantities to
reduce body fat and moisture which can
cause corpse to decay whoa they also ate
herbs
what is that word scissor
say sad nuts and sesame seeds to inhibit
bacterial growth holy [ __ ] they drank a
poisonous tree sap that was used to make
lacquer
so that the toxicity would repel insects
and pro pervade the body as an embalming
fluid pervade wow [ __ ] they went on a
10-year diet to kill themselves what the
[ __ ]
and turn themselves in but you know that
was a thing with the buddha like there's
images of the buddha like the original
buddha that was like he was starved to
death have you ever seen those no they
made statues of the buddha where he was
like basically a skeleton
they're weird statues and that was a i
guess a part of that process see if you
can find any of those
um
skeleton-like buddha statues how would
you say it starved buddha statues but
that was like a thing that they would
they would make these images of the
buddha in this state where he was um
apparently probably going through that
thing like yeah those oh oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] that's like something out of
indiana jones it's scary see go to that
quora um thing what does the emaciated
body of the buddhist state statue
represent
they're not really good not good answers
sometimes by anybody though but let's
see
the six year period of renunciation that
the buddha practiced from age 20 to 36
approximately 446 to 440 bc
based on traditional indian especially
sramana
belief in self-mortification
before he realized the futility of
extreme asceticism
and renounced it as when as well when he
was on the verge of dying
so he
wised up so the buddha did the same
thing those monks did and he was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing he stopped he
stopped what the [ __ ] am i doing i'm
renounced this
but look he had gotten to the point of
basically almost death
so that practice since okay so that's
446 bc so this that statue was older
than that
so the statue was a thousand years old
right it was a thousand bc wasn't it no
no no it was a thousand years for a
thousand so it was three thousand eighty
right so this was pre that
so that guy was probably he didn't get
the full wire that the buddha bailed on
he didn't get the facts yeah he didn't
get the full
details so he decided well the buddha
was a [ __ ] yeah and he quit gonna do
what the buddha couldn't do i'm not a
[ __ ] quitter i want to be a statue
[ __ ] she's gonna be better than the
buddha
but that's
the whole buddhist monk thing is odd
practice anyway right because i'm a
dumbass can you just explain is there's
more than one buddha right or has been
or well there's the buddha
who was like
thought to be the root look at that
image of him whoa look at his guts
i was wondering what if he was like
holding something or what that is i
think that just represented his hands
man that's his uh his hips buddy oh
that's that's no stomach at all this is
organs it shrunk up yeah i think he's
got too many ribs though this just need
to take an anatomy lesson
does he have too many ribs how many ribs
you have do you even know how many ribs
some of it's a muscle 26
i made that up completely
because there's muscle up there but they
look different than the other one to the
left that one looks more realistic like
that one there the the tan looking yeah
that looks more realistic see that looks
like real ribs look at these sunken eyes
so look at the ribs on that one then
look at the ribs on that gray one right
there that gray one looks fake as [ __ ]
it's too many ribs
how many ribs do you think you have i
don't know how many ribs you have i'm
going 26. 26. you mean both sides no all
up 26. i might be thinking of teeth
i might be confused i don't know how
many teeth you have either but if you
think of how many ribs you have on each
side
let me guess let me without touching my
own ribs one two three four
i might have gone a bit too many
i'm gonna stick with it i'm gonna say
22. i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say 11 on each side
12.
12 on each side is it 12 oh 12 pairs
you're pretty close we were right in the
middle you said 22. yeah so but what
look at his though look at that one that
one weird one that we just saw
that [ __ ] guy had like 50. how many
he's got he's got [ __ ] tons like but
that look at that nice muscle he's got
going
you like that look at that nice muscle
he's got going on there bro that's skin
yeah that guy that is that's tendon that
probably that guy can't curl a [ __ ]
peptide of white out
like i don't lift he doesn't no you lift
bro you lift bro how many has he got
there he's got too many
count him he looks like predator he's
got too many they put nipples on him
though too
like the batman suit how many he got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17. yeah he's got
too many ribs they didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing
it's all fake
fake news this is [ __ ] fake news bro
but that's a that whole buddhist monk
thing the suffering thing is a strange
thing i have i had a friend who became a
monk yeah yeah he became a monk while i
knew him he was a friend of mine from
taekwondo
his name was joe and uh we used to train
together and he just decided at one
point in time that he wanted to uh go to
this uh
buddhism this buddhist temple to learn
buddhism and to to he wanted to get
control over his mind because he got
very nervous during sparring and got
very nervous um when he when it came
time for training and and competing he
competed a few times too he would just
like lose his [ __ ] and he was he's like
maybe meditation would help me get
through this so he started meditating
and taking these uh
like buddhist practices and
doing this time at the temple and then
switched to a strict vegetarian diet and
then completely quit doing taekwondo and
just became a monk and we used to go
visit him
and uh we used to go visit joe the monk
where did he live at a monastery yeah he
lived in a monastery he swept up at a
temple
it was very odd because i knew him
before that and you know he was a guy
that we would train with yeah right and
then over time he became a monk
and you know he
silent no no he would talk and he would
laugh and joke around with you and stuff
but like you would only eat vegetables
and he would uh he would never speak
badly about anyone or anything it was
really interesting did he see him happy
happy's a weird thing like what is
happening like he didn't seem content he
didn't have a mate he didn't have a wife
or a boyfriend or he didn't you know he
didn't have there was no one in his life
that you know
he it seemed like it was just him and
meditation and silence and
he would like uh he had a co-on you know
like there's a thing you're supposed to
meditate on i think that's what a koan
is and like his was the sound of like it
was like one of those the sound of one
hand clapping thing oh yeah right i
don't think that was it but it was that
kind of thing where it's true falling in
the woods around well it's you're
supposed to think about it like
constantly even though it doesn't
necessarily make sense and the idea is
like that through that you somehow or
another achieve enlightenment by
focusing on this one thing over and over
and over and over again
i mean when maybe that's like some sort
of a brain hack
but i remember i was a kid at the time
when he did this i was uh probably 16
something like that i mean it was 15
when i knew him and then maybe like 16
17 when he when he became a monk and we
would go visit him it was very it was
very strange we'd go to eat with him
we'd have to eat vegetables
would he come out and go into
the wherever you were yeah he was like
san francisco and go and have
drinks this was in boston he would no he
wouldn't have drinks no way he just
drank water and tea
um and he was uh
he was different man like he he was all
in like he had decided that that was his
life and you know he was subscribing to
all of their belief systems and their
practices and
did you and your friends ever at any
stage think we got to get him out of
there like maybe he's being brainwashed
or something or no i mean he was older
than us you know it's like we we weren't
in a position to tell them what to do
because we were all all of us were like
uh around the same age maybe they i was
the youngest guy but only by like a year
or two and i think joe was like 30-ish
so we were like teens early 20s and this
guy was in his 30s and he was hanging
around a bunch of teenagers well he was
training with us okay he wasn't hanging
out
we were all training at the same uh
taekwondo school and you know he just
decided that that was his life and uh
he seemed content i'll say that it
didn't seem like happy is like you're
around someone they got a big smile on
their face they love what they do like
happy as you catch a big fish that's
yeah right
yeah yeah
he wasn't that but he seemed like he was
on this path
and this path provided him
some sort of clarity or some peace in
his life that he seemed was worth
sacrificing all like he didn't have sex
he was done and we were joking around
with him about that like
like that's it forever no more sex did
he jack off
no no masturbation holy [ __ ] i know
that's what i say
maybe [ __ ] the pillow
maybe you know maybe he's in a trance
you know monks [ __ ] pillows you know
yeah pretended
i don't know what he did you know but he
uh
he was the first guy that i ever met
that sort of like left society and he i
remember he stayed at this temple that
we we knew where the temple was we'd go
see him there i've known people that
have done that kind of left society but
not that deep like they've gone to a
remote island in indonesia and they just
surf and yeah you know i've heard of
that before yeah i know people that have
sort of like dropped out and you know
live in a small town live in a log cabin
and [ __ ] and i've thought about it i
think it'd be good
i'd get too frustrated i think there's
something to that
there's something to like being in the
woods and there's something to
just being alone with nature
you